[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is that razer phone so this thing kind
of came out of nowhere it was born from
that razer acquisition of next bit a
couple months ago it happened didn't
really expect much from it and then boom
suddenly this new phone and it's
impressed me a lot i gotta say now if
you caught that first impressions video
i was very positive about it back then
i've been using it since then and i
gotta tell you it's been pretty damn
good a lot of the things i originally
was impressed with i still like a lot
the build quality the industrial design
choices and just overall how unique it
is i actually love it now razer is a
gaming company and they say this is a
phone built for gaming but when you
build for gaming a lot of things end up
also being great as a result so on the
outside this thing might as well be the
opposite of the iphone 10 where all
these modern phones now are shooting for
this sleek curvy modern pebble look
razer phone is more of the boxy squared
off brick and i kind of dig it there's
only one color and razer told me it's
the same matte black that they use on
their laptops and that makes sense here
and it's been surprisingly good at not
catching fingerprints as you can see we
all know matte black can catch a lot of
them so that was a pleasant surprise the
one thing about the back is this logo i
wish it wasn't in this little cutout it
might be laser etched but because they
put it in the cutout it feels like it's
like this sticker that i could
accidentally scrape off if i'm not too
careful it feels cheaper i wish they
just put the laser etching right on the
outside of the metal everything else
about the outside of this phone though
is prime i'm telling you huge
front-facing speakers quad hd ips
display clean lines everywhere obviously
well hidden antenna lines and at this
point no other phone looks like it next
bit robin obviously you can't really get
any more but that was smaller and way
more flimsy and plastic this is that all
metal beast but the buttons are terrible
though i wish they ditched those buttons
from the robin but you still have these
tiny but more importantly really mushy
buttons i've been trying to give them a
chance since i first got them but i'm
really not a fan the power button also
being the fingerprint reader you know
that's cool with the placement the combo
makes sense for unlocking your phone
without thinking about it but it's not
very tactile or clicky so stuff like
double tapping to open the camera feels
mushy so i just stopped doing it taking
a screenshot etc i just don't enjoy
pressing these buttons and the volume
buttons are just lame i wish they were
bigger clickier just a lot better good
thing you don't have to press those
buttons very often though because we're
going to be spending all your time
is that display that 5.7 inch quad hd
120 hertz ips display i am
so glad they did this i'm so glad
somebody finally decided to do this ever
since we saw the pro motion displays and
the new ipads the high refresh rate i've
been thinking about it on phones i
thought maybe the new iphone 10 might
have it it didn't obviously
and obviously these high refresh rate
displays aren't new but it's just
something different about it being at
the touch of your finger that's what
makes a difference razer says they did
this for gaming and i get that gamers
are obsessed with frame rates and games
always feel more immersive at higher
frame rates but this is a 120 hertz
display also through scrolling through
the ui and messing with android and with
your apps multitasking etc so it's all
twice as smooth as any other android
phone ever has been it actually makes me
not mind scrolling as much like i was
cool with spreading out my shortcuts
across more home screens and leaving
stuff in dumb out of the way places
because i didn't mind scrolling to them
because it was so smooth long lists are
actually fun on this phone it sounds
weird it's kind of hard to explain and
it's impossible to even show in this
video on youtube but you gotta see it in
person or trust me on this one and the
actual display panel itself is pretty
good looking as well despite not being
oled which doesn't exist at 120 hertz at
this time it has some solid color and
contrast some have said it doesn't get
bright enough i disagree it gets bright
enough for me to read outside it's just
that there's not a huge range of
brightness so it doesn't feel like you
have much to play with when you try to
turn it up and also auto brightness is a
bit wonky and inconsistent but that can
be fixed with software pretty easily and
speaking of software the razer phone
runs pretty close to stock android
now right now it is on top of android
7.1.1
fingers crossed it'll be on 8.0 oreo
sooner than later hopefully by the
beginning of next year but it is pretty
clean and it essentially takes the
oneplus approach of just adding a couple
features here and there where it's
useful and the phone is already a great
performer with the snapdragon 835 and
the fully ridiculous 8 gigs of ram
and gliding through your settings you
can see there's not a whole ton of extra
stuff there's some display settings to
cap the max adaptable frame rate some
management of the expandable storage and
there's a game booster and while i
didn't find i needed to use it to get
great performance i did find the do not
disturb while gaming mode pretty useful
that just straight up stops any and all
notifications from getting through and
interrupting while you're in a full
screen gaming session nice
but basically the biggest customization
that came on this phone came from their
decision to use nova launcher prime as
the stock launcher out the box which is
awesome nova has a ton of customization
and plenty of android users know that
already i think that was a great move so
then on top of all that if all that
didn't have you convinced razer phone
also happens to have
the best speakers
ever in any phone that i've ever heard
so there's that these are separate
stereo front-facing speakers
independently amplified and tuned
specifically to blow your mind now these
are great basically they are so loud i
stopped connecting to my google home at
home to use as a speaker i just toss the
phone on a table wherever i'm at in the
middle of a room and that is the
personal jukebox instead of the google
home it's kind of amazing also pro tip
the alarm clock volume in the settings
on this phone
is all the way maxed out by default uh
so if you don't adjust that then the
first day you wake up after buying the
razer phone you will be absolutely shook
[Music]
my decision
[Music]
okay battery life uh turns out it's also
amazing i mean i guess we shouldn't be
surprised by a phone with a 4 000
milliamp hour battery and near stock
android but it's true this thing killed
it i originally thought when i got this
that they built the lower frame rate
caps under 120 hertz to save on battery
i think they kind of knew that 120 hertz
that would kind of kill the battery they
set it by default to 90 hertz but this
thing has had the longest battery life
of any phone i've used this year at 120
hertz i set it to 120 hertz when i got
it and haven't even tried the other
modes because i've had such great
battery life the last couple days i've
had five five and a half and six hours
of screen on time with extra battery at
the end of the day to go so i'm not
really concerned and i haven't even
bothered trying the lower frame rate
caps because i don't think i'll need
them all right so this one has a lot
going for it so i think at this point
it's time to talk about the one thing
that'll probably let you down about this
phone and that is the cameras this uh
this this camera isn't good and i i kind
of had a feeling going in i mean it's
not a big focus of this phone anyway you
know you're building you're building
something for gamers does a gamer really
even need a camera at all not really so
you know they threw in your typical dual
cameras that you kind of are required to
have as a 2017 flagship phone but don't
expect this to do anything above the
bare minimum of just capturing a subject
if you really want a more detailed
explanation white balance was pretty
inconsistent and i constantly saw color
casts which is unusual uh dynamic range
was just poor just weak af exposure was
hit or miss depending on if hdr wanted
to kick in or not uh taking a picture
and actually focusing itself was also
pretty slow and everything every photo
and video you take is just soft soft the
front facing camera same thing
clearly i don't have a lot of good
things to say about this camera but uh
you're not buying it for the camera
let's just put it that way now it could
always change and miraculously get a
software update that brings it from a d
plus
to a c plus that is acceptable maybe but
i doubt it honestly this is an actual
deal breaker for me and it's the only
reason i can't keep using it as my daily
driver and while we're at it uh no
headphone jack and it's 2017 so i get it
that's been the trend but i think razer
kind of miss out on an opportunity to be
another one of those phones and
manufacturers that listens to the
enthusiast and gives them what they want
right now i think that go-to enthusiast
phone is the oneplus 5 or the oneplus 5t
and that's because oneplus listens to
their fans and they know that they want
to keep the headphone jack around i
think that's a missed opportunity for
razer i think they could have easily
kept the headphone jack around on this
phone and not have had a problem and
been again one of those enthusiast type
phones also the vibration motor in this
phone
trash straight trash i'm gonna call
myself so you can hear this
it sounds broken like it's but it
sounded that way out the box since day
one so that is the razer phone i gotta
say it's a really strong all-around
gaming handheld wrapped in a metal
jacket plus the sim card that turned it
into a smartphone but really the only
reason i can't keep using this phone as
my daily driver is because the camera is
that bad and the pixel 2's camera is
that much better but i just don't want
to leave 120 hertz this really is the
definition of a deal breaker and i know
a lot of people throw that term around a
lot you know oh this phone isn't water
resistant that's a deal breaker to me
but like is it really though like unless
you're constantly dunking your phone or
constantly walking around with the
threat of mist or water you'll probably
be fine without that water resistance or
like you know it doesn't have wireless
charging that's a deal breaker no
headphone jack deal breaker
there are annoyances for a lot of people
but this camera is an actual deal
breaker for me to the point where i
literally can't keep using this phone
so i won't be i'll be switching back to
the pixel despite that though the rest
of this package is the real deal and i'm
super impressed with this being their
first try how well considered and well
executed this actually is and i can't
wait to see more 120 hertz displays
coming up in phones even if i have to
wait till the next razer phone to see it
so that's been it thanks for watching
talk to you guys the next one
peace
[Music]